ma se ti dico di no e no asciughi sempre
mio nonno pasquale sono imbattuto da un
sogno ho sofferto molto torna a casa ha
preso la discoteca amici qualsiasi 23 c
guardare cio fa lanciate non guardare ma
pensa te lo voglio solo sangue io
comando non lo faccio un pigro sono
fatto perché
non fanno di man bambini si reca per
nascita o per comprarlo santino comando
ragione come re leone mi lascerà tutto
invece che essere la caronia si
conoscerà bene in questi casi umani casi
clinici a saga burro per la chimica
educazione siberiana educazione civica
esternate come john in molti in vecchi
volti nuovi e tutti i personaggi a modo
rispettati come toni
mani casi clinici e pavia burro per la
chimica educazione siberiana mica
educazione civica teste matte come già
molti vecchi volti nuovi
tutti personaggi modo rispettati come
come dopo fiore un portico fai adesso
propone mera frati tutto nero come una
bandiera lei si spoglia nuda quando
viene sera quando sempre il culo sotto
la mia amici amici giudei for you the
wire c ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]
poi ho poi si youtube italia è qui
insieme a favi
[Musica]
io l'ho conosciuto mi sento un reboot
youtube italia sono qui e sono malata
come faccio io a curarti come faccio io
a guardarti meno male che c'è lorenzo il
mio amico adesso io ci penso l'ho
conosciuto a milano e finalmente fallo
scribano
e mi pare il puzzo lento pdl teese
[Musica]
ora posto la canzone a lorenzo è il
ritmo lo devo prendere prima perché non
so la canzoncina
ecco grazie ciccio che sei qua perché
denis ma stava mangiare
usiamo il
bella la
[Musica]
basta
questa è stata molto pincio questo caso
è stata molto molto molto grigio però
grazie a tutti di essere qua oggi in
questo momento è la parte più ci sta e
chi so much problemi primari thank you
the kids ciccio take you for four bm
friends and everything you did e il my
life vecchio di cosio from the sud bring
somma happiness sud nord
piraino a ny no e no guys buona chi è
nemico senza pd è nemica piovega lemmi
puccio cioè intorno a ding che because
we need to play
because my name
[Musica]
e poi cosmai nemi spalle
beh va beh hai fatto la rima anche in
inglese di cose e non per il gioco di
ieri abbiamo già ieri aveva girato in
inglese quindi e poi inglese come si
chiama quel gioco lì quello là del
derubare le cose quell'ora che ti ruba
non ha voce
ci stiamo rivedendo vabbè dicevo che si
chiami più gioco latif qualcosa tf
simulator dirsi moneta ufficiale corista
allora praticamente oggi volevo fare un
gioco all'insegna del giallo nardò
grazie mille voleva fare un giorno a un
gioco all'insegna del riprendersi le
cose che sono non sai come la monna lisa
abbiamo subito è quindi questo gioco si
chiama tip simulator che praticamente
l'ho portato uno anzi aspetta molto le
cuffie comune dopo portato un altro
niente è un gioco dove tu devi rubrum
delle cose che tu sei un ladro devo
andare a messina pensiamo a messina
dobbiamo rubare delle cose in questa
fascia star erano tutti contenti ma
dobbiamo rubare delle rocche allora
l'ultima volta che ci ho giocato è
veramente difficile non era cagando di
rientrare a regate di capire un attimo
come sono fatte le case devi rubarmi e
qui niente dobbiamo capirci giocato un
abitino data la città molto carino
secondo me l'aveva fatto l'ultima volta
non mi ricordo un mesetto fa forse un
pelo meno mi sembrano qualche settimana
fa e niente adesso adesso riportiamo
siete tutti contenti che ti stanno
sudando tutti in chat beh son contento è
nuovamente ciccio ringrazio per essere
per thing as sarebbe stato quando
ringraziò realtà dove ringraziare perché
mi dà l'opportunità di essere conta è
non so se pure è una bellissima persona
pro ii crediamo volevo detto davanti a
tutto a youtube italia ci parliamo un
attimo
così da allora ti spiego come funziona
funziona
qua dormi che grazie allora ci sono
messaggi che cosa ci voglio tuo kay va
bene
grazie mille aurora un bacino usato un e
remind della serie ricorda gli elogi ccc
imposta sveglia al settimo alex grazie
alla ex allora tu hai ti spiego come sta
roba è veramente strano però tu hai un
computer dove ti danno gli incarichi su
che cosa rubare poi c'è black bay che
con tutti i soldi come cose rubate che
hai fatto ti compri le cose belle ma
belle veramente da morire ci fai tipo la
casa famiglia di fi
non lo so è nota ma che non lo fate ciò
che vi forum ruba punto il non si
affitta ladro punto it e tipo rubare le
coppe di sviluppo e rubare i quadri
quindi per questo l'obiettivo trovava
montanelli si spera di ritrovarla allora
adesso ciò 30 a 861 dollari richiesti è
successo ma quando ho fatto assistito al
dio vabbè questi back bay tu vendi la
roba su blanc che è già qua invece
acquisti suggerimenti su come entrare
nelle cause che finiva in 50 dollari non
khamis per un po i powell di spina di
poco il mazza 100 100
è un sacco pagava più economiche andato
sui lupi watson dai facciamo acquistiamo
i suggerimenti sulle misure di sicurezza
della casa possibile ubicazione del
bottino la rutina inquilini ce l'ha
puliamo chiave niente ti dice quanto
quando escono di casa quindi quando poi
entrare ok robe domenico proprio come si
legge da routine c'era cosa che creo
prete volte le note bravo di martin
baker
ciao sono andate la vega esatto quello
no quelli non in quelli quelli che già
ci ha portato la trincea torino bottino
lavori info e non è dare info che ti
sconosciuto senti facciamo le 4 di notte
dormiamo andiamo a darci un'occhiata
l'indomani quando che abbiamo come sono
più ma va bene ragazzi adesso leggiamo
tutto fatemi solo dormire che dobbiamo
inquadrare un attimo e poi un gioco
veramente strano eppure sembrava molto
figo cioè l'acqua
vedi anche in realtà è un simulatore
tipo tecnico al 2004 nel mattino e ti
sveglia mezzogiorno 6 tipo tutti come ho
fatto oggi da dormire alle 4 dell'una è
esattamente quello che sappia niente che
sia vero e proprio sembra quindi poter
fare il lato e lei si fa rilevare oggi e
non ti insegnano prego rubato mentre la
più bella somma per la pagina di silvio
grazie marco grazie mille poi andare al
banco di pegni a vendere non ho provato
a greenville street che il quartiere
dove rubare le cose questo e come rai
paga rubare tutto fin dai
[Musica]
vabbè ragazzi questo è sto cercando un
attimino di ricordarmi questi giorni
anche grazie francesco verri gentle
molto gentile
allora tu devi guidare la macchina
questa faccenda alle mani elvis
invisible si spera perché sono contro la
macchina scassinato la mia macchina
lo so che questa ti fa uscire che
succede il festival e no perché poi mi
ricerca la polizia del regista da 30 a
fare tutto ma che se lasci la macchina
in mezzo alla strada mentre derubi dalla
mafia de scherzi e orribile che possono
capire come si apre la mappa come si
apre la mappa rea beko sicuro ed aspetta
primo gioco ci sono tipi controlli si
faccia autobot inverti nella intera jima
pipa blog che ho visto al corri
interagisce la mappa la mappa non c'è
problema ma non la apriamo chissenefrega
dicevo io come si chiamano i tipi che
dobbiamo rubare di nuovo sul prezzo sono
il 112 quindi andiamo al 112 che si sta
da sei ok fondo proprio i numeri è
veramente molto da ridere sopra che si
trova tutto a posto però tutto bene
tutto bene quel che finisce bene
mamma mia che viene addosso è colpa sua
da tre ormai si ferma non c'è
retromarcia
grazie fratello
va bene questo sia un quartiere francese
se un romando stiamo cercando la
monnalisa incontro speriamo ce l'abbiano
i watson d'amico is ours di cose il
demoralizza isa world hanno scritto che
devo fermarmi qua fuori privare i
piccioni andy è ok tutto io voglio
vedere un po come prima e vedi la parola
clima perché già da quando dovrebbe dare
fastidio
già però se mi vedevo chi non l'ha
troppo in giro ci ha provato a derubarmi
una volta vero lo sta facendo
sei stato ascoltato non in pino
chissenefrega pino sto facendo niente si
sta soffocando col cuscino attimo che lo
sai che bisogna dobbiamo al contrario se
questo riesce a dormire sta dormendo
sotto il cuscino è caduta una politica
che ho fatto ma cos'ha fatto
17 del tuo articolo su una persona
avanti non è mai così amici vaio ma a
posto e io dico basta cioè nel se non
c'è bisogno
vabbè ma chiamata polizia via scappiamo
scopriamo vabbè allora diciamo così la
routine e che di giorno stanno lì e di
notte non dormono per che dormono di
giorno appena dormendo di simile fatti
fa torniamo di notte una vita notturna
con la vita morcavallo ci siamo mai via
è molto difficile
allora andiamo a casa cercare la polizia
dice che cosa fai balliamo la parte a
casa e non mi segue più che bella casa
un garage con un pezzo di sopra è il
piacere è un mark brunett corda qua hai
visto bene è esatto
quando mi sono sempre chiesto cioè non
ha casa e poi c'è il mac da 8 mila euro
vabbè rubato all'interno della black dei
ricambi nell'auto speriamo di no
elettronica cucina attrezzi per ladri
punto com e ci sono tante cose tipo la
microcamera del figlio e allora se
possiamo rubare qual è l'obiettivo
possiamo rubare due kin 2 sul gioco cioè
si può giocare solo in uno credo è bravo
per la rosa definita per hobby sono
gioielleria quanti arrampicata grimana
dell'automatico io punterei a sbloccare
questo perché questo pati sblocca ma
come porte dormiamo passo la giornata
dormire di in spagna a ruba sonora
mezzanotte ma anche la vita quello che
si fa la vita ad ormea 8 così in tromba
almeno dormi lo invidio tu che sei
esperto di queste cose ciccio dai dimmi
un po di rubare la macchina cosa più
facile del mondo si entri e va bene gta
ci ha insegnato la voglia allora green
screen views street
siete pronti brolo abbiamo seguito con
l'elettricità questa qua si chiama wi fi
e non ne so di più stare così non posso
tocca giocarci niente devi stare
perfettamente al centro per due ore di
live non muori va bene l'elettroshock
fanno così anche voi carcerati speravo e
probabilmente e tu cosa fai all'una di
notte spiegamelo cosa stai facendo
ma poi con sponde formare un po che
succede quel che lampeggia tipo e marca
l'inquilino certo centro per farmi fare
alcune cose ci sono comunque delle
storie che puoi seguire poi anche non
fare il nome non me ne freghi niente
lavoratori acquisti questi pop un mezza
marcia via devono stato o magari si
tratta secondo me è difficile rubare in
casa ma ci proviamo
non posso fare brodo allora la
parcheggio lontano così non se ne
accorgono che parcheggiato attenzione
che se troviamo qualcosa di valore di
pesante lo mettiamo qua dentro nel video
un bagaglio sottolineato che se molto
allentato vediamo un po se ti capita
così come se fosse una moto si no ma a
casa mi ha cambiato la camelo casa la
allora queste 113 è sbagliato
era il 112 beh scusate volo rubare
vicini
ok questo non credo credo
non c'è più ci sono i cuscini
paranormali serratura livello 4 no se
c'è un modo per entrare acqua chiusi
queste tv sky uguale al frigo vigilanti
posso fare per questo skyrim aspettative
proveremo mentre un polo l'audio non si
ferma l'azione prospettiva sento una
mazza se durante la solenne o non fatto
almeno uno dei due per collezionisti
infatti infatti si sente ambia ambienta
ambiente ambiente blocca durante vai
certo però sono scemi anno si apre la
serratura livello 1 anche la porta ci
siamo allora tutto quello che vedi
possiamo provarlo ma attenzione perché
se mi scoprono un casino allora non vedo
niente alla flashlight rom più ruba il
dipinto il bacio lo voleva monnalisa
innevato la testa del bacio abbiamo
sbagliato ecco l'ho preso l'ho preso ha
preso le lenti sono molto lento
richiedevo dove andare per le visure qui
la mano ma adesso prendo tutto se
tranquillità per biechi e come all'ikea
qua per vedere se sono già montate
contento e fantasma una bellissima vi di
natura del ladro io camminerei magari
non non c'è nessuno e sociale centro
cammino con turati vero del plasma roba
che c'è uno che forse uscita di cori ma
devo posarlo per riuscire si trovano gli
oggetti aiuto non si uscire lascia eh eh
ma lo lascia avremmo avuto e avremo
tutto penso
esatto bravo aspirante miss tira brasile
bravis
no c'è un tipo fuori che sta passando
fuori come vorrebbe ne sono accorto
facciamo passare poi c'è capito da dove
lo spiraglio parlerò sta per passare il
turno
ecco quattro un uomo sinistra wow
siete il pd che sera ad un altro stava
arrivando a tutti cosa stanno facendo
alle 4 del mattino col se si lavora male
sono febbre vuole il lavoro e le 4 del
mattino da farlo per me sta cosa
quando sei nato a londra ma cos'è non lo
so dove siamo in review non è un'idea
pensa in america di sicuro non è napoli
preview quindi rom più ruba el'abbiamo
fatto c'è una costosa macchina iaf e in
cucina bravo facciamo così accomuniamo
la roba qua
ecco il carrello ci sia la notte
prossima col carrello andiamo regalato
l'apologia mente proprio la moneta
dentro
poi venne il ticket di casi dai per di
un euro esatto la porta costerà una
serratura semplice però abbiamo fatto
perché l'ha fatto
sveglia visto veramente si è svegliato
alle 4 alle 5 del mattino
vabbè facciamo che dobbiamo questo e
basta perché si sia addormentata
documento comunque poi sfondare anche le
finestre il problema è che ci siamo
chiariti c che andai che si è svegliata
per lavarsi i denti play capace
ora per in bagno cioè coach torna a
dormire forza come se facciamo così
andiamo a caricare il quadro buy
quanto farebbe ridere fare un pò paolo
14 gigante lo portai ciò che egli scorta
e la porta di ingresso del lavoratore
detto sappiamo sta roba quella del 113
come mai queste informazioni urca dove
veloce che c'è qualcuno sta girando
l'angolo
molto bene chiude a questo che la sta
facendo sta pattugliando la prossima
notte andiamo alle 10 perché questi
panno americani ma il 2010 si svegliano
alle 5 in chi ho capito prova ben
quattro ce l'ha non è la gioconda ma è
un passo avanti ragazzi e pian piano ci
arriviamo
guarda che c'è davvero tanto di modo
arrivarci dobbiamo arrivarci ragazzi la
giocando da sempre dai per forza aver
rubato al bacio solo quello ma secondo
me riusciamo a trovare di più ma ho
capito male a ventotene automatica no
faccio la donna prende pure telos di
visto però poi mettono come si pensano
di seeweb bellimento o venderlo su ebay
inquadra cento cavallari tra l'altro gli
ha riconsegnato di pre allora affitta
lato come che si vende grazie panino
benché sua marcia se in modo gentile a
ricambiare come si fa ecco come si fa a
vendere la cosa che abbiamo appena
rubato lega come la vendiamo qualcuno
che lo sa
su affitto lato la soffitta no
blackberry affitta l'altro è arte come
si vendono qua no però non me la chiede
quindi semplicemente incasso i soldi e
la vado a vendere al banco dei pegni
giusto ora ne vale banco di pegni lo
vendiamo
la prima se lo lascio quale vediamo poi
tutto domani sera la roma facciamo bello
tuttora che non rubano a me soprattutto
noi che ci pensi gli deve andare al
banco dei pegni per grazia andiamo al
banco dei pegni però dopo prima andavamo
a dormire facciamo sulla serie il
mattino dormo fino alle 10 di sera per
forza perché come come faccio aspettare
tanto tempo arriva al isole farne 10 che
bella vita che bella dormito un sacco
dorma il robot non mangione ha capito
non mi piace questo ce ne sono state ma
qualcuno dice il cibo per il vero bel
niente proprio niente opposto ragazzi
però io ho guadagnato dei soldi non
vedere quanti soprattutto il suo tendone
del pc per va bè green street
allora il banco dei pegni ho capito
ragazzi allora niente niente banco di
pegni andiamo continuare a rubare le
robe lì e poi appena abbiamo finito
andiamo tutti insieme ai banconi vecchi
e buttiamo tutto che dici cisco se tutti
ci arriviamo qui al coming o semi capace
di cose più senso costa di riparazione
un dollaro
questo spaccato della macchina un
doppler che altro un dollaro che si sia
fatto uno stuzzicadenti del governo
questo è successo niente costruito nella
macchina non sprechiamo dollari di
macchine allora davide morabito di
chiedere il 16 a ciccio che sono un suo
fan e vediamo rapito
io ti amo amo il fatto che tu per far
chiedere da me doni quindi grazie un
aiuto anche lorenzo si fa poi te li do
atelier di riposo
capita un boomerang grazie mille ragazzi
tra finiamo questo e poi leggo tutto era
già perché mi sono fermato da un po così
dove ad essere quindi tanky comunque
allora ed evitabile perché sapevo che la
mia è il 2 con tutor e vito perché lo
sapesse anche montatore è vero ma questo
è dovuto in contrario
poi qualcosa in contrario no ma lombardo
le persone lo so ma mi il mostro è da
provare il punto esclamativo lo puoi
pensare polizia c'è uno che mi fissa che
mamma mia
questa facendomi fare l'altro pazzo va
bene ti abbassi in un posto più bislacco
oro bislacco e sto scherzando
dovrebbero riprendere gli altri due rom
b che stanno lì lavori cosa con la porta
al sicuro
vediamo se c'è qualcuno malattia che sta
dentro dove che dorme esattamente l'ha
richiusa tutto come se niente fosse di
tivoli ha aperto bob è aperta no però
rotto il c di mandello che pirla vederlo
adesso è nolo rotto adesso non posso
contare meno che non faccio tipo neuro
bari non ci credevo spaccare la finestra
squadra che ho rotto il grimaldello che
pirla
allora facciamo così magari non mi
sentono
via via la polizia
subito è partito l'allarme neanche dc o
che succede via via via compreso un
grimaldello sori non sapevo
pensavo che chiaramente lo fosse non mi
ricordavo meglio questo infinito capito
l'aria che si rompono siro politicamente
compriamo dire mandello sono ancora il
dipinto allora attrezzi per ladri prima
di quella ne andremo semplice 20 il di
vento male dvd uno più forte
hai ragione però il pd mandello
automatico non so il clima
dell'automatico si rompe glielo chiedo
di che ti forniamo le due
nel frattempo rispondetemi in chat se il
rimando è l'automatico si rompe si apre
tutte le serrature perché se sì allora
prendiamo poi solo quello già stato
fatto in tempo a prenderlo comprarlo
intorno allievi a comparti vandelli l'ho
preso dalla fia già arrivato mi creda
canteremo vedo mi ha fatto mettere il
dubbio che vogliono semplice perchè l'ha
fatto ha fatto fatto imprese il nuovo
visto proprio ma questa macchina degli
anni 80 non lo so miliardi ma sketch al
bagagliaio funziona ok
sembra poco alla di giampiero lima
la palla ce l'ha firmata dai dai
siamo all è però in una patente scusami
se non lo capiscono la costa riparazione
donna costo fondato cosa il palo verso è
il pal
porca vacca un dollaro di palo vabbè
vabbè ci penserà lo stavo meglio un
dollaro di paro che un palo di dollari
non so se sai cosa vogliate palo
sarebbero mille euro
vorrei che avesse come la patata
nessuno pensa guardate salve allora sì
comunque prendo le due cose poi corro la
macchina secondo me si può anche fare
non voglio fare quello che si
accovacciano i pasti bislacchi se non la
presero la bild la crono l'assetto tipo
dal 2001 è cosa da una bislacco non la
sento da talmente tanto da era tanto
tempo che significa poi bislacco dei
biscotti bis la bislacca e compagni
bisacco dei baiocchi i bislacchi e
glieli compreso veneti rai way mangia il
gruppo b blog bislacchi è veri qui da me
c'è un rap dopo ci sto la porta con sé
una serratura semplice lo so l'ho già
fatta tanto poi c'è una rampa potevi
futuri eventi la macchina tutto quanti
non lo sapevo per uno guarda con la bava
roma basta per porta per un niente non
va visto che la porta della serratura
sempre tour aspetto certo giusto questo
a posto
ok pronta la roma caraffe in cucina in
cui son blocca
allora in cucina tra queste si trovi
prendere anche oggetti stupidi che ti
infine tasche bronzo
tipo questo intende tra l'altro quello
che manca la porta genoma costo sono
chiari cafè in cucina proceda con le
cose lo sbaglio magari il tipo non sarà
accorgersi averi dalla porta molto caro
non lo so adesso non c'è meglio soldi ti
lascio i soldi nel comodino così così
qui dagli all ass non serve a niente per
poi dormire nel letto degli altri sempre
se non c'è niente dai c'era
qualcos'altro ore della mattina abbiamo
tempo fa nulla
scegliete uno sarà un vaso giallo a
braccetto levi sul televisore dirà a
ecco l'idea era quello aspetta che apre
i cassetti chi mettere scattanti
cassetti brocco
non lo so ma fanno pure schifo quindi
c'è pure di questo orribile oltre a non
saper léman calice d'oro proprio interio
pieno buttiamo roba butti a un vaso
calice d'oro stai scherzando come si
butta robot a lascia grazie quanto ci
prova ma scacchiere ma inutile che tanto
ruba 9 se non qui dove tre oggetti
massimo ok perché all inventario poco
sviluppato e natale passato alcun poi
perché si proceda marlowe è a valigia
ecco se che dicevo le dove televisore
scusa ancora posteriore è lentissimo
nessuno in casa bra bellissimo cioè
quello ke cavolo
allora il fatto di misura il connesso
blu è vero 2 the reasons ne portiamo 2
cioè cipro casa con dei sogni durevole
vorrei solo uscire ma mi sa che mi
conviene uscire di 46 sicuro si prodotto
usarlo di qua devo posarlo proprio
lascialo va bene non importa non ci
stanno la caduta
1 dio mio caso già l'ho provato giallo
d'oliva so già loro assenso e sono
spesso è quello che telecomando ciò
spazio guarda al televisore piccola tv
storyboard ok l'altra stalla c'è un tipo
qui che però non mi da vedere
sei pronto ma passa al tipo destra noi
non ci fa che vedrà due televisori per
terra dice lasciamo lì da chi stai una
papa va bene così derubati direttamente
magari c'è un altro che arriva sulla
destra che palle non o nell'altro europa
con ok non l'hai detto però che non si
sa mai a vincere
stai tornando che è pahlen high roller
come nel mare più temuto dai ladri il
maresciallo non so se vuoi commentare
questa cosa io commetto un [ __ ]
che è ma io non posso perché private nel
mio angelo custode
però fa tesoro no grazie
però no programmi erano però grazie però
grazie ancora quanto a costi benissimo
lo ritrovano e cosi strba all ovest
libro devo fare in fretta a prendere
tutti e due portali dentro questa la
magari mi avvicino con la macchina che
dice fa lotta nonviolenta davanti
[Musica]
soprattutto ma ci stanno due televisori
gordini si lavora tanto non importa se
mi vede perché non fare in tempo chiama
la polizia fa arriva la polizia
spero lo so io nel dubbio non facciamo
noi facevo rivedere si spera sono pazzo
pazzo faccio mai visto ha visto ma
potrei essere uno che sta facendo
trasloco o facendo qualcosa di losco
dice no no no no d'accordo la messa
facciamo la polizia pro scappa scappa
per perdere via via da voltini
arrivai aspetta che non canti evitare di
uscire prima perché doppia televisione
banco ma se vai a casa perché dopo anche
il quadro viene così la sono sul
televisore proprio negativo
forse le ladrocini prima tra tutte spera
ma poi c'è tutti gli oggetti da vendere
su attrezza ladri si chiamano vendi tipo
il calice d'oro 66 dollari pro mammamia
manco amazon
ok di camilla tutto resta entropica il
muro
no perché quelli così così grossi li
portare al banco di pegni lasciati sul
bandissima dei regali regali regali sue
note citavano mi regali quelli calabri
natale non lo so non ne ho idea vogliamo
andare a prenderlo subito
vabbè doveva vedere questo portiere non
lo sapevo no no no no dicevo prima
quindi vaso toro 10.000 a seminare tipo
nei calo con dentro peluche di merda
dieci mille che caduti se non è pagata
[Musica]
per chi si rovina capi prova queste
destino di stare con noi e ne mettono in
ambulanza
qua sotto a sinistra ci sta piace la
città significa che andava a vendere la
tv bancone vecchia fu 4k questo canale
jean che il guar vai e la vendo a un
prezzo che ho una comprerei anch'io
se tu questo qua poi tratto questa
questo per iva e le 6 del mattino anche
alle 3 di notte quando ha citato noi non
fa domande se si perde fili televisore
qua anche l'altro se la comprerà stati
sito lavoro capito lo capisce altrimenti
nessuno per volta non ci sta più
va bene potrebbero 120 dollari al cav h
ha venduto quell'altro che è più buono
la gara è la e la camera con struttura
tutto ok
tranne il quadro quanti sono i soldi sai
che possiamo prenderli grimaldello più
power che avete letto alla fine se si
può usare il grimaldello pa più power sì
penso di sì prima dell'automatico per
per rubare meglio tanto a casa però ho
mai fatto gli stunt pro con me che sono
diversi e dimostri consiglio vuol certo
apre solo le serrature delle case ict ma
meglio
andiamo su taiwan ciao giulia
e allora perché non cantate non so
perché sei araba con ciccio sarebbe il
top
ciao ciccio sono alla giuria che sta
sempre tutelarvi di età ho capito ciao
giulia col bacio tu sai tu lo sai che
non so ci si gioca giulia grazie giulia
la cantiamo rota è una chicca che non so
se possiamo vantare come che sai sono
tipo con le canzoni quelle che sono più
importanti con i canti solo tipo al
super bowl lei oggetto per for you
francesco mele pro messina lorenzo studi
from torino e ragazze nubili adesso
canzone così a ma non so perché se io
faro io no ai nuovi così araba con un
esercizio tour dopo la cattiva strada
allora devo avere aspetta un attimo
legali è successa una roba un po strana
vi sentite tutti sì che è successo dopo
l'altro bsh allora facciamo così un
secondo di pause poi continua perché
volevo leggere vari nativo alle
donazioni
grazie mille ragazzi allora grazie
raffaele nate claudia silvia marot's le
anni
antonella mesi magic giovanni ii
rocchetti e rimarco francesco mazza
quanta gente il trio del nuovo nardò
panino lenardo di nuovo stefano davide
morabito giuliana r andrea privato
ovviamente nico e giulia per l'uncem
ponticino volevo dirvi che per sbloccare
le serrature gli avanti devi mettere il
talento del city
c'è addirittura quello per le casseforti
questo proprio dai senatori difficili
quindi tutte le abbiamo
tranne tranne questo che però sarebbe la
prima queste forti capito questo
consentì di ha battuto valido deve
votare gli oggetti sul posto da
prendiamo questo perché tanto a meno che
non vi da un altro punto talento e poi
ci vediamo questo che apriamo la stessa
forti non solo livello 6
vabbè tanto che se ne frega di gettare i
mattoni attacchi alle parti allora
prendiamo compriamo un grimaldello di
quelli più potenti e stanotte andiamo a
rubare nelle case di ricchi chiesto
1.200 dollari però il ben spesi
mamma viene anche da casa certo si
chiama io ho fatto microsoft era un bill
gates una scusa mi toccherà le mie poche
rare
capita poi entra ci sono solo a ieri lo
sa per chi si allena pure a casa ridotte
allora diamo un'occhiata a quale casa
prendere prima di andare perché siano
sentiamoli cerchiamo la casa ci mettiamo
troppo né un occhiata si è detto questi
sono tutti amici
è bellissimo gioco mi ricordavo sentivo
veramente devi stare molto attento alla
routine che fanno le persone quando è
rubare a casa loro perché non sbattiamo
le parti entriamo lo stesso se ci
riusciamo bene sono case di ricchi
banche in più sul tu dici intorno alle
19 a marca l'inquilino però quello e per
storia c'e una casa più cause di quella
di prima basta però c'era casa la
pazienza di prevedere solo presidente
sarebbe la casa se non puoi neanche
entrare tra le quali puoi staccare la
corrente sono come capita ma si rompe
perché se si rompe non lo voglio usare
automatico a cui schiacci si apra tris
tacchina corrente capito ma con
l'intitolazione di tragici ma non mi va
di staccare la corrente realtà proviamo
glielo st català sicura giorno
semplicemente tuglie la stacchi di notte
grazie a zio luca della stacchi di cotte
così che dovesse si sveglia non
accendono le luci possono chiamare
nessuno quindi tuoi tempo e poi alla
porta ovviamente il grimaldello ma il
clima dello livello 2
devi avere per forza di mandello livello
2 non può avere livello livello 3 parco
lemonia
facciamo così occupa ora il problema
prof
nel caso è il tuo posto questo strada
che blocca questa incazzato perché se la
fanno
guarda che è stronzo stronza vedi che
puoi fare anche così giovani ma
realizzato dedicata ad ovest a quel
marcio almeno in canada che poi che il
moonwalk con la macchina che stai
facendo
guardava e fan di maicol però
l'approccio ma la stessa
ti prego per questo deciso la macchina
va detta perché non si levano acqua la
vita e ve li diamo scherza non te la
vita un gusto ha smesso di lamentarsi si
sta più lo fa apposta però vabbè non ci
mette un po essere investito a propriano
ragionamenti puoi fare
sorride vabbè l'esodo estivo era perché
dovevo devo chiudere qua ok vado ci
provo
e stato ferito un pedone carica uncem al
mago ti fanno ritornato vero prima spero
assassin chiedersi chi vuol dire e non
lo so non ho capito stava bene però la
macchina e qua e là ti va non c'è più ho
dovuto investirla averne non ci fosse
nemmeno meno male che non è finita
peggio divisi grazie luca niente finito
comprende mandelli divisi facciamo così
come non so quanto prossimi prima negli
divisi in due o tre ro balbo valutata
sia fare la spesa all'esselunga attimo
un attimo dalle tradare centro scusate
turbare lo vedrei comprende mandelli in
pochi
ciao ciao questo o quello secondo turno
non avremo elettronica senz'altro
elettronica però scherzava scherzavo
scherzava dove andare via scherzavo
se non aver ragione dentro ai capi hanno
preso
a scappare poi caricare al check point e
molto easy pensavo fosse molto albero
che sono in galera per tutte cose nomi
che quello è un problema e aspetta mi
chiamo messo in dubbio detto madama era
non ti prego di molte cose che vogliamo
notevole della macchina nel canale vado
piano quello delle nano ciclette pesca
rubare 239 al volo ovi store ha visto
provato o no madara proprio quasi mai
salvo poi vabbè dai mi faccio prendere
l'entusiamo non da tre incazzatissimo
questo farebbe perché era lenti ma non
ho mai capito questa cosa
grazie giambò max e grazie jack di razzi
juster fare giro da dietro la moto devo
rubare due tre ore perché non so quanto
basta in di riemann dello medio capito
se questo qua questo mille quello
costato 500 se non ascoltando musica
rock che questi di bianco che non
sentono le cuffie rose tipo strano tipo
di 20 miliardi praticamente si faccia
qualcosa forse poi puoi arrampicarti ma
con agilità livello apriremo un credito
ci guarda qua
insomma come ma come estremo già capita
ma dai
e no posso imparare solo il primo dei
che faremo il secondo non ce l'ho ma
tutti ci vuole passare di livello
minchione sacco di punti dai ma che
sfiga ora come l'esselunga di euro per
le piccole cose poi sono di livello di
propriano è cosa ormai quella questi che
sfiga assurda per un metro di ma neanche
dal semi motivi anche sua marcia in più
grazie mimose un grande di marcia grazie
mimmo strage che blocca strada che
blocca cosa vuole fare le idee siamo
venditori portato a roma perché non
possiamo vedere se non dei 20.000 auto
parcheggiate in un posto strano tra la
bislacca molto può sembrare strano
bislacco avevo la tentazione di parma è
visto per quelli vabbè che facevano la
casa e vedo quanto ci vuole per prendere
gli attriti mandelli peccato per vabbè
tanto saliremo di diverso ci siamo molto
stanchi di mandello bonaretti
ricordiamoci il quadro si è
si no dai 76 non presidente dai 6.000 m
per scola vedo l'ora ma davvero è pronto
è il momento è bravo per te la bottiglia
e 107 anch'io intanto io voglio bene ti
va bene anch'io tanto questa bottiglia o
dove invece sono i miei deve fare doveva
fare il vaccino ha pianto un sacco cosa
porta l'acqua devasterebbero fatto write
vi ricordate la serie d a way out wei
wei per dire come ha scritto wade hawaii
quindi hawaii five o pesci
raga importante questo traguardo per me
andare a rubare in una casa che merita
di essere rubata rubata porre fine a
questa cosa
quindi vederlo da lì è bellissima
proprio da solo si fanno sti prego
[Musica]
valenti quanto dante alighieri belle
uguali pro con il profilo è quello reale
ragazzi che stai guardando a darvi prego
fate uno screenshot è modificata come se
fossi tante ok guardare questa sera un
ben di dio
ripeto è un profilo incredibile ora che
c'è un che di artistico nel tuo profilo
perché è proprio ai proprio una buona
come come va giù e tipo un reale 124 e
qualche bel è anche tre è che quando è
vero 12 il 2 il 3 bello lungo è il 4
giugno e il 3 ecco che arriva al margine
è puramente artistico al massimo
bravo comunque noi perché abbiamo fatto
questa cosa io mi sono interessato
sempre innamorato del tuo profilo
non solo serio me piace anche a
programma che è falso la media esatto
spero che abbiano screenato ragazzi fa
tempo di dante alighieri smos l'ufficio
che penso che ci stia allora weight
stesso di tutti quelli classici sempre
fatto molto bene come tanti va bene
erano le nuove cam persino i nasi
aspetti che devo di dormire fino a
questo norme sono aver già questo entra
dorme escher rubato santoro a dorme fa
nient'altro che questo spero non ci
becchino quello ancora mi sta chiedendo
pensa quello è nelle missioni quelli per
inizia lì dove non hai neanche il
grimaldello è proprio così io sono
andato avanti di prova benefico sì sì ci
sta solo che nelle case dei ricchi
dovresti può controllare con la video
calcio è fare robe assume la propria ma
non ha voglia
vabbè però andò 7 dollari
questo non lo so una roccia per te
audi rompipalle un dollaro rompi una
roccia 7 esatto
cioè sui giochi la famiglia che casa
anche così non so dove per la macabra 5
note circolari perché è più che altro
tra che usciamo quindi la metto qua però
non so benissimo
vabbè tolgo la corrente si vedono ma
libro io lavoro ragazzi che sta il
profilo di leo caruso è chiarissimo
verissimo
la differenza è che non vengo tradito
almeno da lorenzo una realtà quindi
dispiace però però in giro mi dispiace
tantissimo tu lo sapevi
non lo sapevo lo sapevo poco si
ricapitola tu lo sapevi sto zitto 246 18
20 44 minuti poi l'assorbente cosa sono
per i bambini però siamo andrea
addirittura ci siamo 3 o un addio non lo
so come si fanno mai fatto come obbligo
pro è vero però poco sapremo brodo
tutorial giusti formativo aspettavo ma
usi 0 blocca cilindretto
o come detto
prosegui grande club il napoli cosa che
appare che che timing tipo sta arrivando
adesso
wow mamma mia wow blu non avevo è il
romanzo di paul in garage e ma non so se
sia professor ci vuole un po di hacking
per il qatar ci guarda incapace
meno male sono sollevato mi sto cagando
sotto perché non so che parte andare
un minuto 2 minuti ripidi due minuti è
una macchina per rubare la macchina
tanto cioè si tratta una una colonna
sonora un po vero sì
feci fare questa cosa sto ragazzo ma
dormire collegati ai regali prendimi il
tuo solo lega libro verde blu non possa
che dare uno stop i regali ma so perché
i regali per i bambini per lo più felice
un no che un no che poi c'è il samsung
bibbia la bibbia un'altra bibbia la
bibbia bibbie 113 secondi abbiamo però
poi riaccendono tutto immagino lo so
ecco dove si allena delle cavalle se tu
ti rendi conto mentre in una casa di
riguadagnare la gente però poi ci sono
affidate ticino paranoia soldi ai 50
dollari nelle case dei ricchi così
proprio salvadanaio potrebbe portare 100
più grande come si fa ad aumentare si
può aumentare telefono marathon e brunei
stunt 100 si può ragazzi aumentare la
capienza dello zaino ma sicuro però ci
sarà un modo per fare di pozzallo perché
mi serve è proprio la capienza aumentata
nello zaino capito ma che ma è ora lo
sto gioco è mamma mia
voglio dire di no inventario pieno dice
che va bene si provi a volla sacco di
voti di carlo lo prende qualcosa di
gigante che ti metti nel bagagliaio vedo
che sono in ansia partigiani ma i
partigiani caricarti il genio il dash ma
non c'è nessuno i soldi qua poi mezzo
giallo no qua mi che è pieno di roba
dovremmo tornarci 27 secondi dice che ti
opposto che molti davano momento riano
fiori e brolo o si tu no devo avere
livello 4 pendeli darà al naso di solito
154 per chitarra no non lo sollevi con
le mani che peccato
44 secondi vuol dire che ritorna a tutta
la polemica si accende la casa hanno
chiamato poliziano ha scritto scappa via
via via noi abbiamo come una scocca
scorgere no no no no ma che non solo è
alla macchina via via via ci torniamo ci
torniamo ci torniamo mi sono portato lo
gado hanno chiamato la polizia nas con
iseo scappa potrei anche nascondermi
caricamento telecamera telecamera va di
qua mica polizia libro clip quale tempo
adesso è normale visto una lista meno
visto prego no preparando persone sono
scemo no io no
peccato un albero
bravo peccato un albero in faccia che
pirla ce l'ho fatta dai allora davvero
l'unico per fare tagli la macchina da
commenti del post in cui tutta libera
davanti
secondo me è questo lo zaino 25 gli
spazi in più di me lo sai
però dai non è più tabù messi se l'ho
detto scappa scappa tonon e facendo
vedere questi vede niente c è lo scemo
io re che non sa bene non ha ben
sappiamo come muoverci quindi adesso non
sappiamo come muoverci sì però è stato
difficile che pirla o che lascia acqua e
se facciamo però la polizia arriva di
l'ha capito quindi dobbiamo rivolgerla
di qua e poi salvo subito no crediamo
che non arrivi nessuno marcia piena di o
blocca vero prete fondamente un pò
biglietto oppure polonia ascoltiamo nel
cassone ci scordiamo
ma io non volevo nascondermi perché
magari si beccavano di frutta
microcamera dentro capito attivo dal
bravo luce la luce luce propria guerra
già che pirla e no aspetta che c'è però
la gente sta arrivando
sto correndo uno che corre a jogging
mica sto facendo niente faccio dagli
hard ma è difficile non la possiamo fare
i grandi lo dovevo bellissima in
ansiolitica incredibilmente sta cosa che
ti da questo è bellissimo per il tipo è
passato tempo che passando la rubata dai
è roba qui devo dare un occhio alla
minima paterno chiamiamo apparsi sono
bravissimi ma sai perchè perchè
veramente ho giocato tantissimo oblivion
ma tantissimo
pure io sud ha fatto di questo vino si
che poi ha fatto rampicata poi entrare
anche da dall'iri difficoltà ma non
potevamo entrare pirla sono tanti
stupidi blu siamo veramente stupida rosa
ecco il naso che ci avrei anch'io adesso
con grafica mamma mia che botta addio a
uno prendi tutti intorno joystick per
videogame video che la console a
chiamata video niente ok della pony
della poi panino davanti due cassiano a
vico video due casseforti non una bros e
poi prendi i pacchi di doveva prendere
perché no applicato mi devo ricordare
assolutamente di prendere il coso per
prendere
nelle casseforti entriamo poi per solo
per provare le casseforti
ma come abbiamo preso due aree la video
console nel peso rubrica perché faccio
schifo di peso massimo capito bene un
regalo preso padella o magari siamo
cacciati dice che vuole dare tutto c'è
nessuno quando ero al collo e ma non so
se se se sono randò mitch fatto che non
ci sia nessuno capito magari ok alla
camera nordici
fidiamoci di me stesso e non 130 secondi
soldi io e devo puntare a quello perché
tanto l'inventario pieno quindi soldi
soldi soldi e basta rapida infatti
infatti eccoci così la ronda show 52
quali sono sicuramente non domi c bari
al mille per cento però profilo avrebbe
sul tipo di uguali o a prima che
diventasse c'è una pianta esatto pianta
vivendo sarà ostrica pianoforte prima
che c'era la roba la maglia dell'inter
noi interisti ma c'è una torcia ma se
volesse chi è piero lacorazza disturbi
sufficienti 50 copriva 150 83 abbiamo
ancora tempo per farci un altro giro
veloce
comunque devo ampliare assolutamente lo
zaino raga perché sennò come
70 secondi proporro poi corrono un
puledro libro forse 150
sessanta secondi a 30 esco 59 poi perché
ci sono tantissimi 40 50 ancora tempo
per uno di mazzone sia la storia
finocchio ma vediamo vediamo la presenza
che impazziscono 30 search giocare col
pensiero 32 st antanarivo via dai va
bene avremo sono soddisfatto vorrei dare
forza che qua c'è gente la videocamera
non ha visto perché la corrente non c'è
che è bello ci andava molto bene
wow pro bari con messinese roba è così
ragazzi con fair the group gru fair
thank you so much e proprio banco ripeto
che devo vendere ma cosa parla il
braille la console i pacchi se vai alla
macchina puoi mettere la roba della
scala c'è una scatola nella macchina
dove fosse poi infilare la roba vediamo
cc domandati il direct sudan tebro cosa
quando insieme vedere se volete ma dove
grande non lo sapevo questa roba qua
grazie verrà infatti aveva detto di
lorenzo e poi scappare anche a piedi
nascondere sotto al letto o bidone
dell'immondizia quindi pure sotto il
letto pro sotto il letto non sapevo che
abbiamo che fai quando stalin aspettive
di cura non passi della gente si sente
soprattutto d'estate può trovarlo è lei
ragazzina imparando non lo sapeva sta
roba come sapone anche poteva metterò
bene la macchina ma figurati grazie ad
una mano incredibile
allora quando ma cos'è e alla play 5 la
playstation eye e mille c'è la ragazzina
se esisterà mai una console di 1.100
euro la romagna che l'aiuterà morirà la
pony ha capito tutto
ma è la tra i tre e regala è però i pro
x four season 3 ho scritto videogame
videogame senza casa con il padre
qualcuno cioè 1500 riavrò madonna la
libreria di tutti i videogiochi del
mondo pero non avendo peli vipere
aspetti come fanno vedere aspetta
aspetta nella mente scrittrice prego un
certo seri da essi ci manda questo si fa
così pochi make up e immaginatevi
affaccia l'edificio fatta mente i versi
di un po
pecchia è perfetto però sei uguale
propano solari tocca a provar movimento
va ancora ritoccato per avere parlamento
c'è un bellissimo ma io questa cosa un
pò terrà in video 21 negli animali a te
non piace ma tu sei particolare così a
me piace tanto te lo giuro non sto
scherzando
chi sei e due ho capito adesso chi sei
il tempo che ti ho detto che se di due
carte ho messo a capirlo ieri blog quale
no vabbè incredibile la mabro assurda
state bellissime dante e quello quello
più chiaro e ciccio non sembra mamma
vieni tu puoi concretizzare dante
veramente se non è bene che lo faccia
provato un telo rosso puoi farlo io
provo a fare virgin
vabbè è stato dice starci strano
complimenti poi mi chiede a fantasy
incredibili romanzo una grande fatti
vedi che amo un sacco le persone c'è uno
perché allora 21 fantasia assurdo noi ha
avuto la cosa dimettere ha mai visto il
bel se non insieme a lui così la regola
era quali essi complimenti un museo
dovremmo averci con capra veramente
tutti ti ha avuto condizioni tra possono
usare il naso perché filati io penso che
non si sa bene a chi li sa chi c'era ora
però dice veramente giusto lungo cioè il
web e contiene solo accelerato dalla
grossa questo nome del roster o figlia
una persona mezza in coperto fanizzi
roberto prova però secondo me questa
cosa ti sta bene tutto il giorno con te
lo dico per dirtelo anch'io grazie marco
risi tropp si dice
veramente ceduta a primo acchito mi mi
vede la prima volta no
timide festività periodici o un naso
lungo se mi vede la prima volta è stato
così il cerchio bella sta calato
guardano video di restiamo naso lungo
certo ma non è una cosa brutta non
capirei bruttone se ci si sta ci sta
nomadi roberto e dc cazzo che fa fine
ora basta cazzo bislacco la kraft
ma poi con il quale 5 del mattino ma che
pirla può capirla bene notte scusami ma
poi io sono venuto qua non per rubare
perché volevo andare a prendere al 7
cosa volevo andare a come si dice volevo
rubare così di fianco per aumentare di
livello per stiamo per aumentare il
livello per lamentarmi l'agilità tutto
qua così intero in quella casa
bellissima
wow allora posso mettere cose nella
scatola e tanto vedere se che le cose
che ho preso questo vendere sul
blackberry tipo i pacchi devi
raccogliere 5 qualche blu quattro pacchi
blu fa ridere quattro pacchi blu mille
dollari 65 pochi blu mille donne una
cosa a tutti quanti cioè 6.000 6.000 se
ne prendi 16 per 6 rossi 6 mila 4.000 a
no
aspetta no arancioni sono 6mila però
sono stati quindi quello sotto è quello
sotto non c'è un angelo 6 mila sono così
rari
ciao marco ciao juster di zubiri gamers
e bella fiber art e ciccio sempre nella
zona
manuela la ragazza perchè sarai
soprattutto grazie a te
torazzi affittato puntoit ricompro di bu
rompi in un lavandino proprio la piena
decorativo budget non avverà lavorativa
lo perché chiama nazione degli miller
suggerimenti sulle misure di sicurezza
della casa che ho comprato con un'amica
l'ha letta chi se ne frega ma non le
composte 9 tanto lo capisco di mio non
solo guardando quanta roba possiamo
comprare da parte tutti ma vuoi prendere
quadro se vendiamo sostegno ci potete
sul presunto leone spetta
dormiamo 120 tanto dicono è sempre
aperta per vivere l'acqua per noi sempre
dorme così da una idea che varia da 1 a
100 questo ci fa parlare liberi la
guarderei one ha idea di cosa ci aspetta
faccia mt cuffia prendi approvato dal
tipo non so se parla però se parlasse
enti come come parla
barca cosa
rossi lo posso mentre penso che no ci
vado banco dei pegni vediamo ci sei non
so se devo dire però prova a sentirlo
cava a casa cosa che l'ha portata di
aprile
c'è uno sconto dunque devo tombe
scusate non v'è una le gambe come ti
pare non sia ai call me qua il noc e
quelle il samsung il santone 70 dollari
5 50 era preso lui si baciano guardati
pancia moanco gli occhi ma ci sta
magari neanche 79 portavi a questa
robaccia da qui il picchio calma mi
piace ai regali calma
stiamo calmi ma qualcuno
un'applicazione di skyrim è bello da
rothschild tenerlo qui sono due tempi
progetti grandi agenti grandi roberto
quando sento queste cose non potevo la
botola che c'è di grave
voglio rubare alla casa puoi dormire
anche dentro la macchina vuota cosa
veramente non mi ricordava 130 giro qua
è poi così gli oggetti capitano figo
guardati atromitos enormi rispetto
totale 4 massimo 15 ma si sa se il
modello semplice non serve kleeman
dell'iri mandelli ci sta dietro
ma non è vero chi se ne frega non
dobbiamo dormire poi appostarsi fuori
capito dormire mancherà non lo sapevo
green street
questo dobbiamo fare adesso rubiamo
direttamente lei no perché le casse
fortuna possiamo rubare che ci serve
cose da 4000 fatto costa 2.400 scusami
quindi la bella ragazza si fa lessi
allunga prof
esselunga java astral che la ciccia cui
chiedo un favore chiedi a dante servita
mischia la divina commedia sempre fatto
in generale astrali auto schiave dire
come sono possiamo i soldi di novelli
qualche modo tu arriverai del cerchio
del
girano la boa del girone voler dello
studioso di imparare la bolgia del male
la bolgia va bene perché ho preso la
missione la missione a lavori e tra vere
con caronte per chi è quel loro solo a
era qua i 1.106 allora abbiamo passati
giorno siano rubare sparaco prego grazie
signor gravi settore trovarci 106
cicciotto ingrasso tutti per te ci hanno
inviato anche da retelit su dante
polegge positivo ci ho messo dalla radio
al folletto felice polisportiva
mascherati non fare il gemito ali
sportivi sono cagato addosso ce lo
ricordava così orribile st terribile
crash col coltello che cazzo fai qua ma
l'orribile è stato bruttissimo rompi
loro vantino quadri romperlo
e da un po si da roma che subentra
merita però il tipo e in casa capi
tavoli staccare la corrente il 106 la
casa è piccola quindi se il tipo e li ha
chiuso luce proprio al titolo con lucio
amato sventando dormire meglio vedere se
si può spegnere proprio aspettando
magari alzati che tanto se fuori ci ho
provato io non si può esaltare non si ma
pochi bar fanno fare una paura che agile
come un topo brodo sul grande maria
amore
scappa non posso uscire presidenti pro
dei piatti a vari puoi farcela farcela
poi farcela propria di del 1 piano piano
pronto davvero palo mentre scappa dalla
dalla vostra l'altro sugli ascolti con
ascolti di nascondigli ma come mi
ascolto dove mi nascondo è tutto chiuso
qua ma non possono entrare anche loro se
non so non so poi perché devo rompere il
loro l'avanti pechino il bollo cure o
sta facendo il giro lesse entra dalla
porta principale che vedo insomma
machine back in qualche modo loro
prostata in casa entrati in casa sta
venendo giù attenzione
[Musica]
contrattacca questa casa con ansia il
crimine andato via piazza non so non so
perché a me mi sa tanto torcia già vista
tipo riesca a paolo qualcuno mi
inseguiva di poema è questo è il tuo
passato lo stiamo rivedendo però andato
via è andato via non ci credo fi po
funzionato siamo ancora in casa arcese
luce proprio se aspettiamo ancora un po
fosse ma speriamo che ciò che si doveva
creare la stella ab latina stella
aspetto un po poi tipo dice vabbè se ne
sono andati andiamo a dormire
non è proprio così intensi risultato la
casa a dormire alla famiglia e tra amici
dicendo vera la polizia
quelle sono già varie vecchie hai capito
non solo lecce vecchie ma non sempre qua
con trova sono vecchi da ieri è passato
dal momento che la divergenza prima con
un giusto lasciato anche l'elicottero
mi dispiace però è davvero non lo sapevo
lo sapevo ma non così l'aveva definita
una vera domanda è ci ho provato
sono impegnato per farti vincere via
quinto è uguale riuscivo ancora in
quella che nel 68 via se magari adesso
anche orami la mia faccio ancora ok che
sono due mezzani a3 a dormire in
macchina del parcheggio già scritto cosa
c'è scritto per dormire in macchina nel
parcheggio
no è sembrato molto buona bisogna andare
mi volto a casa chi sa risparmi tempo
tempio turismo di tempio ma comunque la
polizia che secondo me fa tulli e basta
mi puoi stare fuori
vado è ecco sondata perfetto blu adesso
no che adesso profili c'è io incredibile
problema di dover ricordare disco rigido
ma la cassaforte le casseforti cielo
quale non le posso prenderlo lo abbiamo
proprio si basa sin qui devo solo
ricordarmi sai cosa che per uscire devo
inquilino blu come senso che mi ha
sentito nuovo brucio ancora stella
chiudi la finestra blu nota possono
applicare rimane aperta poi tanto sta
parte quasi chiusa rimasta chiusa gioco
posso farcela non c'entrano tantissimo
amori il fatto e ci sono questo tormento
detto a catarman ma soprattutto dobbiamo
rompergli il lavandino sulla porta dock
è rimasto aperto
sono le tre dobbiamo pero far veloci
perché abbiamo poco tempo vogliono più
belle nate ciccio in sardegna non ci
sono mai stato volentieri si vesta di
sardegna
io no ai bronchi e proprio no ha detto
fuori più baratta da capire a me ma poi
come dormono potevano storti e che vedo
io dovrò per il lavandino palladino esco
però abbiamo senso così andiamo prima ad
aprire la porta di fuori
sì perché se no e non esco più brolio
del momento dobbiamo rubare tutte cose
rubare anche loro le persone venutosi a
nessuno qua sana teiera sma la persona
poi rubare le persone che si procurava
vado di robot lavandina desco così ok si
prometteva evento a napoli ne ho già
fatti male farà sicuro ancora come anche
ci pensa ma spero io sì senza dubbio
lavorando la rossa senza problemi
grazie juster non ho capito niente però
aspetta che devo spaccare il lavandino
sai dov'è no sto cercando quante grossa
sta casa certo che infatti lo so niente
dove ho proprio visti però rifiuto la
questura al naso l'opposto un radioso
questo è più c'è mi piace visto tuscia
che non ho la piri porco la loro mano
del ceco però optato per il pacco blu
che pirla o ma oggi con manco una soldi
come facente un po scappare no spero
ecco il lavandino e questo bellissimo
posso romperlo perché non fai madama
verame
ma non è che c'è solo un equipaggiato no
però sono dimenticati in macchina perché
ora dovrò demoni l'amore ma è tardi
capito
posso uscire dalla finestra scappo
provveduto in macchina poi magari
tornare
sì non puoi buttarti giù a sequel
tavolino dai grazioni domicilio a chi se
ne frega mai vista da come ho visto che
mi ha visto ma non mi ha rotto le balle
perché la pianta dentro la mia macchina
piedi poco fa la valle torna mai ce ne
sono sei
il suo leader
questo l'albo vado aperto la scelta a
carico grazie mille
se mi vede quello che sta passando sul
marciapiede sono morto però loro i pet
sente schifoso lai lo ero qua ce l'avevo
fatta però ce l'avevo fatta se non fosse
stato per quello facciamo salta beh
quello che abbiamo abbiamo questa torna
indietro però manai alla morte che si
spiega da quello perché avevo
dimenticato il piede di porco colpa mia
banco dei pegni non applicato perché
volevo capire
adesso che mi farà aumentare di livello
che non mi aumentato per niente
vorrei prendere le cose per smentire del
no che cos'è il 9 56 quanto volevo
vendere le rose per prendere la cosa per
scassinare casseforti capirò mai pizzo
key gruppo eros tu per tu signore molto
belli mi piace a me la crisi è così che
mi rende i capelli strumenti per
rafforzare casseforti cuffie da gaming
quanto costa 2.500 sono i gusti voleva
youtuber hulk e strumenti per hacking di
mondello elettrico c'è ancora un
grimaldello a per il furto d'auto che
vedo microcamera binocolo come suo è
chiuso del blu sono pare non affaticarti
gli occhi è computer
tieniti pure ci sono un sacco se mio
posso realpower varo soprattutto dal
padova un progetto quindi sto male ci
sembrano acculturato sempre controllato
ben pochi ali o chiaro che parlano di
soli o la visione notturna occhiali poi
c'è dispositivo per colorare il film
niente
il creare il laptop di hacker di altman
e venuto amico dell 86 mila con questo
questo ti fai video lui c'è tu lo
accendi fa lui video delle quali
contratta la fabbrica ma lui c'è ma lo è
pure a statement questa 6 mila euro
picchia po diciamo adesso non può farsi
in questo sito sono attrezzi per ladri
punto com è comunque no per per
scassinare che si è partiti con questa
di livello abbastanza alto e noi siamo
di livello
6 2 ruote a rendere livello deve fare le
emissioni non è un prodotto 9 dove sarei
più livelli praticamente che palle
insomma intorno ai 19 marcano inquilino
perché palo poi marcare inquilino o dici
che va bene non fa niente facciamo
un'altra roba al volo a un altro roba al
volo esselunga essere un gara dice
vorrei cambiare facciamo di parole si 16
st
sì sto facciamo un occhiata vediamo se
fai pensare gli rompono lavandino
andiamo noi resta qua starò male londino
pro ma che tutela il prix di porco nella
cella macchina è come se lo chiede sul
poliziotto d'andare in questo voto quasi
volevo l'attentato cioè magica ma mista
scusa un attimo che donano mangiata gli
amari il parcheggio che dormono aspetti
che devo annidati quadrotte al
parcheggio e questo sono nel parcheggio
come si dorme da mini pro sapevo grazie
ragazzi allegra in dieci
perego effetto bene sto gioco malavoglia
fortuna show come parcheggio per poi a
chiunque era stata bella davanti quello
che mi vede in modo bislacco un po
bislacco staccando un pochettino se la
vuoi vedere mamma mia che spiega ecm
spagna ecc
la serie siamo qua a chi lo faccio prima
dalla dormire per incutere paura a te
stesso a chi ai ladri ai ladri anche se
sono al quinto piano chi se ne frega a
metà mese o stessa cosa che poi ci
appelliamo occhi di bue tipo le luci
esatto mi sa che hanno rinnovato i soldi
in giro c'è loro li mettono a posto
grosseto come che cammina se un attimo
tranquilli perché mi carico cobra si
trovano che cammina tantissimo
tantissimo se volevo cammina tantissimo
a switch router switch
no no stupro per dirla non lo so vorrei
evitare di farlo con fisco malissimo
cazzo dormire è tardi preso quelli con
l'insegna capito sul miglioramento 20
capitare no ok saremo sopra successo
cioè buono a lui i soldi in garage 15
ore in garage
sto pagando addosso però cipro
andati in bagno però come equa ma se
piccato 12 loro ampio
scappa scappa scappa anzi la scopro
nascondi di ansie ma arriva arrivare
spazio dove non importa lo so io sono
fatta cioè quello stava sopra al ces
impegnati che sto vedendo però si terrà
la ri ma chissà per la bonino perchè un
colloquio è stato super c'è real che
spiegami perchè devo il lavandino a un
tizio è un po bulletto vabbè c'è un lato
pure bulbo faccia di aiuto questo vento
di spendere punti vita inutilizzati la
scalabilità
magari ci è rimasto degli extra magari
capienza è salito di livello o vai sarei
ace rampicanti da in uno spazio nello
zaino spazi nello zaino zero nello
spazio lo spazio più che si è compreso
stato un bel regalo blu telefono flat 9
c very good
non lo compro in questo stato pulisci
neppure possiamo parlare pulisci lo
pillola bellezza della musica ma cosa
per puri cioè appunto culo non ha capito
va beh secondo me lui ha dei problemi
nella sua vita non lo so come mai ciò
questo dubbio come non pulisce
dell'africom per 900 euro un po problemi
cioè dice chi lo vendo trova proprio al
centro per demolirlo eh sì va beh
ragazzi
direi che pa usiamo mi sono molto
divertito poi correre fino al confine a
piedi però secondo me la più conveniente
la macchina ragazzi si e voi
salviamo e stiamo un po a chiacchierare
un attimo fa una partita no yeah yeah
yeah
leggo le donazioni ultime che non letta
una mazza very very good visto divertito
molto carino
maggiore è stata davvero figo so che
allora è stato è stato molto divertente
ero io che lo riguarda entro ci siano
delle colonie in qualche modo grazie
mille ragazzi grazie volevo martin gara
sinico ciao si serve dumais per i
peccati presta bene a me un bacio mi
scrivi rigo
grazie mille grazie al bon hicks grazie
smr slime custer valeria juster in
ashley è danilo in francia sky live view
allora io però settimana reparata al
volo
a sto punto insieme facciamo ed iniqua
ah già è matto come la base come la fai
avere cerca robbie williams candy e le
demenze araba e me lo dici adesso che
dovuto rappare center appare dovevo
inventarmi una tempo bastava chiedere io
è il nome di khanty robbie williams lo
candy candy candy istruendo chiaramente
sì sì e ritornello è comunque english ok
ok
per ora basta così ciechi verdi e 2
milioni strumento sorgendo la gente che
canta sotto porta dei brand
wow questa cosa
[Musica]
e tu mi riguarda la madonna gesù cristo
è dio allah non so perché sei araba ma
vi piace comunque spetta rifacciamo
veloce devi seguire me perché non ce ne
sia una canzone dei modà
ciao
è il tu vieni qua ma la madonna gesù
cristo è dio allah non so perché sei
araba mi piaci comunque sei una donna
araba kewei ei come il bari sieri fuck
you like hell sigg.ri più [ __ ] è
futuro del loro dico io perché ogni
porta sono racconta insieme a me 23 o te
lo dico io io sono come dio ei suoi
pregare ma sono sempre qui a guardare io
sono ciccio o berlino
ti voglio bene ed io franche un panino
lo ha detto su di lui è unico nel suo
genere perché lui io l'ho vedere ea su
vieni qua vanno maturati su cristo ed il
botto perché sei alaba ma mi piace
comunque indice è luca moduli di oramala
giusta galla
ro ro il forfait thank you so much
grazie mille proprio stato per me è
veramente una bella veramente è un
piacere l'abbraccio è vero ma la fun
cool hunter un cazzo allora ciao ragazzi
io sono falli j
io sapete ormai da un po di anni che
lavoro su youtube visto sono un po
cambiato cioè primaro più magro sempre
più grassetto più finora c'è un po più
grassetto diciamo che questo è solo un
cambiamento oggi iniziano a giocare a
giochi molto più improbabili come che ne
so zombie per la station 1 volevo
portarvi che ne so qualcosa di veramente
bello
voglio veramente farvi capire quanto voi
parliate per me voi per me sede ossigeno
voi siete per me davvero non span span
voi per me siete non so come si può dire
acqua addirittura la gente ha sete voi
siete la mia acqua così posso bere tutti
quanti voi e potrei sopravvivere per
anni gli voglio bene queste sono belle
parole dolci parole molto profonde base
del mio cibo la mia acqua la mia
salvezza è anche il mio tutto quindi
ragazzi
io gli voglio davvero tanto bene e
adesso però voglio tornare nel passato
quando ero un po più magro bella tutti
ragazzi ho fatto che nel futuro hai
fatto meno in futuro si cos'è che hai
detto esattamente se devo rivedermi
questo pezzo della live
cosa ve ne tenga che voglio la pace nel
mondo no quindi quello che hai detto
hai detto quindi sì esattamente non l'ho
muovere un po perché stai stai tipo così
per massimo fermissima perché tipo c'è
una roba strana che ogni tratto sidis
con lei ma ero collega quindi lo giudico
minuti sidis colleghi collega di città
allattato io gioco con questo s4 s4
gioca è sì sì che il film è molto figo
ecco la ps4 cielo perché non c'è più di
un programma esterno che riconosciamo
proprio ora che il 24
no no no no io però che a me rischiosi
ok mi devo abituare ma perché se con
oblò ha voglia
niente comunque detto tutte cose molto
carine verso i tuoi fan ti ringrazio
ho detto che sono ossigeno acqua e cibo
per noi cioè mirando al cannibalismo
penso a cibus uno muore senza mangiare
mamma mia
loro sono in launchpad cinema come lo
video del giro un po quello che già si
vede tipetti qua e studi qualcosa pro
siamo distanti vabbè dai fare uno sta
roba e poi vediamo
ok perché sei tu io sono l'altro perché
pochi google
vabbè fai tu la partita privata ok può
farla faceva non l'hai facciano al iron
live propone il nostro ego
io sono tu sei me e io sono il 2
giocatore 23 che non so come mai atleta
peso l'uno però tu hai per tempo e di
impostazione aspetta però non se non
dovesse tuoi ai perché giù in modo
diverso il senso ad acqua io per quando
sull sei pazzo cosa me la fanno fallo tu
chiami tasti se derapata a sorin e sta
bene
cakes giusto scherzavo volti varia io
andavo volta questo fatto ma sei pazzo
è vero ha detto no e mi salva detto lui
solo sbagliata ma anche dei consigli su
come mettere telecamera molto bravo ma
lui comunque menti sono anche cose
braille o l'ho sentito stamattina baron
ces così perché vogliamo registrare una
roba che questo vediamo neanche tutto è
successo
per i non cambierei mai i tasti mi
sentirei pazzo io avrei mai abituarmi io
quando mi viene bene aver osato fare
dunque su quanto abbiamo in questo qua
vero sì questo caso è da pazzi
io sono a destra e lui a sinistra come
siamo nella webcam
esatto vado mai andato si va da scopro
con la mia macchina di mi sentivo bene
tanti trovi bene ci sia in questo caso
io questo è il miur anche quindi se
perdiamo ti ammazzo brodo ultima live ha
fatto milia ha fatto il nome vittorie e
una sconfitta
ebbero allora acqua sulla stessa cosa di
partito sempre prendendo con l'io tra
l'altro chi è quindi speriamo di
prendere gol subiti tranquillo pro quale
faccio vedere adesso di che pasta sono
fatto
all'asta siciliana si è complicato per i
quali la viper o non troppo con la
spararla no sono cook si rivolge di
plauso è vero mi arrendo vero aia ci sta
ci sta
yo yo yo ma ci sta ci sta
ok ok ma dai toccato il club butta su e
non era ma mi piace che tu celesti colpi
tanti è capito è che l'ultimo stint di
cocullo
se c è da un po che da quando giochi e
smash hai smesso di giocare anche team
veramente da wow cioè [ __ ] morire
bicicera dovere tra i primi gioielli
sono molto presto festa è quindi chiaro
quello con gli scrivono con gli iscritti
al campionato la parola il lavoratore
quello di stormi vai vai
bravo effetto biliardo i fatti lo la
paletta tira ma cazzo pro sono spaccati
cura tutti però stava pure non mi piace
la facciamo ste figure bird bird non ci
sono leader continuato essere sarà in
visibilissimo è più magro di m eccolo
qui eccolo
ti è piaciuta a me è piaciuto aspetti
che ti arriva fallo le fanno perchè
voglio imparare a smash un'opera del
momento veramente ema mia vita che punto
è la prova
studiano cadenza agio nel senso ok si
trovano un po forte e bello però sai
perché sono più alti che abbiamo da era
da più anni quindi comunque ci sarà il
numero di insegnanti pronti e precisi
tutte comparto potevi condotte dai joy
assai simoneau tantissimo vorrei capire
tante cose che con questo di meccanica
di tempismo tante cose che devono
scegliere i personaggi capito se poi ci
si diverte a voi amavo e dunque mentre
in seguente giovedì diverti quindi sino
a 106 mezzo ci sono pro troppo troppo
scusami ma posto giusto perfetta per
aprire wood che ancora note bird ciao
ragazzi per quelli che stanno dando
andarla a varazze sogni d'oro abbia
ormai condottieri della notte perché
sono appena svegliati il tributo
fratello nicchia
l'ultimo troverà delle ber ha invertito
gli orari si aveva questo
perché dice provincia dove lavorare la
notte per che cosa vi cambia si sta in
camera
non lo so c'è silenzio il giorno c'è
casino
sì magari specialistiche qua tirapugni
non ho paura che non ha paura di idee
siamo 30 per il romics
la prende lui wow nokia occhio chiocchio
molto bene aspetta la ro ma l'evento che
super fan culo
dai dai cazzo mi ha sì sì no no entrata
lo straniero cosa qui dovrò 3 a 1 a
tranche di preparare menu e a un minuto
e venti tavoli parcheggiate capitan
frizione
guardando al vecchio
tornatore scavalco però scusate vado io
tira là dentro la butti bravo l'altra
porta pro passato cosa preso hai visto
era una grande casa dove verrete colpa
del carroccio guarda qua secolo di merda
che l'ha avuto
ovunque birdabroad [ __ ] un gol buono
notturno
butta la punta allo stesso come impianto
ac maledizione piace però bravi
attaccanti fondamentale lo aspettavo
perché 1 vai vai se buona o poi volato
troppo fatto levata del protesto una
presa dal board non ha demolito 6 anche
personale box incassato paolo vi spinge
ancora tutto marzo cioè collega colpa
colpa è mia
ho fatto una cacata assurda guarda
spogliatoio a barolo lavoro di farlo va
giù
chi ha consegnato concerto si chiama
bicchia certo ma che poi dopo anche
delle piccole che devo dire tutto il
toro tetto della casa ci ha notato le
cose non hai mai detto no soltanto della
nostra casa era piena di jackie di
jackie onassis jackie di tutta casa e
dobbiamo per terra brocco ma come eros e
scherzano veramente sistema lojack
italia gruppo fa niente 44 al 90 da
reali sono recuperati e sono di messina
sicilia
dovevamo solo dire la parola provo
quindi potrà però ok provato abbiamo
bravo però che dici però tutta la frutta
proprio pro lo scuso non sembra la
bottiglia pro brazil bra
vendo visto un trancio bravo veramente
paura ma bravi a vincere però la devi
toccare la butti dentro butta dentro blu
blu blu blu oro mai più mai più
vabbè mattino è più vai vai più o in più
no programma libro però che partita
persa che non davamo perdere però
successo di questo è un peccato non mi
sembra troppo bello guadagnarsi punti in
più comunque sono erano platino 33 bella
la skin baro no non erano problemi uno
schifo loro due
perché insieme si è cacciato blu che vai
vai blu perché non ho idea
ok rossoblù c'è un futuro facevano
schifo ci hanno cacciato con gente
schifo hanno un ala diamante ed uno è
visto vista vista allora no scherzavo
era un po come la diamante uno è dovuto
alla col procuratore
ciao fit team
ciao brocchi mi dice che ci dice siamo
agli iscritti di i saluti baci avrò mai
però ma procedono a questa volta però
diciamo che sfiga
bed bath baby come
no no turbine o va a casa tolto come
cazzo hai fatto come cazzo hai fatto
bros e il gol ce la metto una merda
guarda cosa parlerà c'era l'accordo ma
[Applauso]
che viene a garda che via di merda no
ero io che devo andare tranquillo questo
stupido a gioia 69 sica sono fortissimi
però così becco che questi sono
veramente quest'anno platino tutte e due
penso questi erano vernò sì sì sì
assolutamente
questi sono veramente forti perché la
cosa e vincesse contro di loro da
d'appello sarebbe carino america prima
in confronto non ho niente già già già
già
dai su rendiamo prendiamo sicuro può
quando abbiamo fatto di esserci ancora
non si sono altro gol ma il diavolo ago
bene anche avrebbero mai però avrò
[Applauso]
ma perché ciao ciao ciao
l'ho messa dentro però cosa l'ha
imparata pure provato io cos'è successo
che cosa è successa lo alto mi cadde
addosso che non ho neanche saldato
brusco faccio sacro e ci impegniamo
benissimo se lo faccio pro brutta brolo
struttura ben sicura ma ci sta ci sta la
lista delle difficoltà
mi guarda se lo rifaccio un'altra volta
bravissimo cagato provengono da stagista
porteranno caso da ma com'è possibile
che vieni merda per andare su rocchi ha
spinto tranquillo niente no ce la
facciamo ancora no dai a super contro
fare due gol
[Musica]
no certo che no
[Risate]
no ero sbagliato l'ho sbagliata pur
bravo pro ormai più pro ora o mai cazzo
più proprio tabù ma io avevo niente non
demordo non devono soprattutto non morto
ma terzi mor di mardin
ok no però mi sento caduto vai vai ti
questa sera pc pensi se perché no però
se vinciamo veramente cioè me ne vado
vertità più ridicola del pianeta erano e
sono stati 56 secondi a toccarci se non
si faceva bene decidi tu
niente tocca la tua cara fuori bravo
ok minuto
perché è proprio bravo tiratina la tua
devi saluti dalla mente uccisi e tre i
bike pro 11 nono minuto e 12 dai avevo
visto che adesso possono ancora farcela
brody rendiconto abbiamo siamo 3 a 2
speriamo much too much e la tipo anche
brutto tokyo non si fa scavalcare dai
vai con cui compreresti quanto era nel
febbraio come glielo avrei però guarda
dentro guarda più chi chi tocca tocca la
fortissimo bronzi mondiali 4 no guarda
cosa fatto cos'ha fatto sulla parte lo
preferisco dall 80 al mese come sta la
riprende vicino fibra ti prego problema
anche a quei 30 secondi
vado io ve bru
stiamo sognando
dopo poco però da quanto segue
chinchilla ti dico però a chiunque vero
sì l'ho toccata ma le esprimo vivo la
nuova rivive bravissimo domande
concernenti indietro vabbè che i grossi
solo con quello 20 secondi non ti fa
scavalcare ti prego ti vengono perdiamo
con la lenza ti prego tutto quello che
[Musica]
però al contrario a dire no no però se
con agraria daisy ggg randi ragazzo
bellissimo sta minkia al bar pancu lo
sentivo già pronti a pavia fatto
l'ambiente sia su di te una cosa forte
l'avere wat l'ajax grazie
spero che esca più di con quanto sono
uscito io quan to grow quello no
sicuramente se passa è sicuramente più
di me molto poco molto poco anch'io
secondo me dico io sono ha ragione siete
tanto quello esatto 66 non siamo finiti
a fare i dottori del genere però beh io
avevo silky tutti salutati con formali
aiuto per me il nome sì perché altro non
poteva però vabbè vabbè tu sei merlino
quindi marino quanto quello di 166
lei si sente conto che 60 se manco i
muli e senza che sottolinea ci sono pro
vigente lo so però cosa brutta drocchi a
te prof
vabbè mica pace
però tranquillo ci sono io so bravo
portato via dal vento
no l'ho toccata male però forse quello
non ne sia addormentato mica puoi
toccarlo ancora puoi toccarlo ancora poi
toccarla ancora matri ha parlato qui ma
abbiamo tutto ponendo attenzione una
bella cosa faccia il bravo e buono potrà
ancora che non vi sono tutti fatti non
c'è nessuno
vado volo da quell'ora dicembre
molto meglio vai vai vai vai sorry
ho visto che non era tranquillo
tranquillo blu prima decisamente male
abbiamo vinto
silvia cutrera diamante non vorrei
direttrici sa che c'è nel senso che
abbiamo attuato dai dai dai
ma la neve bagnata ha giocato cayman
punto com
ora vado altri spettatori prodotto
sincero o no il diavolo che si ricava
dai vai
che è successo bravo dal mezzo che è
cristo di dio e corro e loro no mi sono
visto dalle tele detto della valle
mamma mia che prodotto tali tecniche e
mezzo
ecco la comproprietà vabbè toccato bravo
no non ci ha creduto nessuno fortunato
veramente stavo facendo cose forli vi.lo
bello ok mai però se data solo erano più
cose e va beh
ma è bello spirito al palo hanno preso
il palo
non hai è la scalogna di tutti i colori
per kyoto perché io faccio schifo perché
perché bronchi ed onesti io ho definito
uno solo contrario dicevo ma tocca pro
turbo ma turbate che esiste ma no non ho
allargato alla caterina stiamo posto
aveva dato una botta di lucky
incredibile
oddio per me non è successo dentro tg 2
1 mi hai un gigi dell'amiu rosa ci
riuscì mamma mia cosa faceva occhio palo
no mi viene in passato sopra
bravo bravo baila è solamente un grazie
ha detto piano piano che ci sono a
mettere la vettura 20 dispiace che
abbiamo contagiato gente né con
l'incontro è scusato ragazzi fino alla
era solo nel frattempo però sarà
vagliato ai ensor sori tocca tocca la ro
ma belle che faccio schifo avere
successo
9 ha fatto una gran cosa lo zio proves
tra è vero è vero bros
bravissimo mai niente ho tolto lui
mandava lo devi andarci subacido bacci
su molto bene a sentire un casino però
non tirerà non tirerà perché io la paris
e io ero con vigardolo guerra quello che
ero convinto di vivere
l'ho toccata eppure vi sarà infatti
sembra strano cosa ho fatto
dimmi che se segno la donna cosa ho
fatto avevo fatto una roba di controllo
incredibile è quello visto però se mi ri
succedeva rimuovi se segnavo se segna
voli ho fatto un controllo
ho fatto un controllo che non riuscirò
mai piacere ho saltato in aria
son caduto dove la palla mi è caduta su
aprea controllati incredibile cosa ho
fatto e non saprei rifarlo potuto
predire una merda
chiti di lomè ai vari no non l'ho
demolito turbo noi ci abbiamo ancora
tempo e filati che come se la butti
dentro adesso la buttò io magari non la
butta nessuno abbiamo un break ma si dai
mi hai un raid in parco lo schifo terra
morto cade 98 pro quando c'e tipo
capodanno non tiriamo in palanzano circa
si chiede che è successo per usura lo
hanno suonato così il bordello
[Musica]
abbiamo a indovinare chi prova a
indovinare dominare il number one di s
lo conosco ma non lo conosco io lascio
di presenza lo conosco bene
introduciamo niente siamo introduce c'è
anche jean è venuto a trovarmi mentre
stava ma ci hai visti che stavamo ancora
il live quindi sembra proprio detto
vabbè allora parte che ho aperto la
porta di là non so come come fatto magia
ranieri però gravissimo ma è passati ha
detto ok il codice è quello che non dirò
perché se no invece naturale
ho detto la nostra sbagliato che c'è la
cancella ok porta aperta
hai fatto un codice strano secondo me
come scusi ma ci hai fatto un codice
stranissimo senza governo
esatto e allora ok entro e citofono
ciao avanti comunque vabbè stavamo
realtà chiedendo mancavano ben ventotto
minuti
niente questi 28 diventare una ragione
di esistere dice che possiamo farlo
c'è però dai d'aereo del momento sì sì
perché lo voleva bianchi estivo e noi
v.bo aspetto che devo capire se non lo
so allora ci proviamo non lo so neanche
se posso suonare l'arpa non l'ho mai
fatto in real time mai nessun video
non so se riesco perché se non ho mai
visto suonare un lancio dal vivo manco
io però come lo riprendo detto così io
metto così io si vede proprio come fatto
che è veramente difficile brufolo è
detto così è come suonare lo string back
esatto però è un po più mi aspetta
ragazzi ci proviamo
[Musica]
aspetta un attimo non so perché non l'ho
mai poi tratte da un po che non dai non
va bene
abbiamo fatto le premesse per i liguri
coraggioso prova posso solo cosa succede
che devo aprire cosa aspetta mente da
tempo chiamò perché di tanta questo è un
è un hardware come possiamo spiegarlo
hardware hardware armi ai di strumenti
meccanica di precisione che così sono
d'acqua di hardware
vabbè comunque tieni tutti gli orti di
parlamentari comprati produzione sesso
libero e 50 pure sopra siamo esatto ma
io non penso di riuscire a suonarlo mai
così se i pacs più basso basso ma non si
vede niente si vede così ritenerlo però
è difficilissimo fare
non riesco i suoi fan passa di poco la
telecamera bruno l'ideale sarebbe alzare
la camera e in china è basso mai
piantata contro il muro vino si può
perfetto è così perfetto però sicuro da
voglia un percorso mettevi così dai
lanci pad store ha visto grande al cibo
detto assolto dai ma secondo me l'ho mai
fatto in live vero ma il fatto è che non
so non sono allora non conosco una
canzone completa ci sono tutti i pezzi
propria brook rea non crea una sega devo
fà improvvisi anche ciccio improvvisa
io so fare solo quello di martin garics
per improvvisa devo fare il beat basta
la prima facevo fatica l'ex prima to
fail bit noi aspetta che si avvia e
pensa quanto ci mette solo il programma
questo era da è da un mese che non lo
sono quindi figure marshmallow no solo
martin garics ragazzi purtroppo c'è
perché non ho avuto voglia
beh allora questo è il programma che
vedete solo voi in questo momento perché
non vedo più cosa
di chi lo ecco quello che si sa più
niente leoni poli mammamarina
[Musica]
ok quale mi mette lanci pad 4 per
settarlo io so come farlo pensa quando
avrebbe dovuto scoprire la prima volta
questo che così non toccare ci sono
molto curioso ma sto cazzone va bene
mamma mansoori poiché queste sei spetta
si sia staccata posta questi momenti
così spetta lo dovrà poi ci mette ma che
sta lottando ci metterà i 30 secondi
poteva di stallo dall'alcol ha del tutto
suo cammino nostre due minuti o secondi
raga lo faccio solo perché mi avete
chiesto però io non sono io non so
suonare il gene senso sono pezzi di cose
però non sono proprio umbra è come
quando io sono l'ocarina in live per i
miei cioè io mi locali nella no non so
suonare località ho imparato qualche sua
canzone di dragon age sentito la canzone
di lughia di pokemon due era ancora lì a
l'ocarina la sua sulla sua farlo era
[Musica]
bellissima mamma mia che ghiaccio
fulmine nella mia casa ed è bello perché
richiede ricchi ricordi che si tempo con
gli anni 90 che prendono ma nello stato
lo sento in questa dover formati 6 ci
sono piani di enìa alto il cuore ma il
si sente tra l'altro attraverso il
microfono quindi sentirà di merda però
vabbè finito non sente tramite desktop
semplicemente no perché quella in causa
di sirene che sarà una idea di che
casino perché c'è dovrebbe finire
l'audio quando ancora caricano la fatica
di berlin in 32 minuti per un attimo di
s apcom pete tu hai il gateau che ti
riprendono audio destra udc si situa
prove di desktop se l'audio esce da lì
direttamente finisce in live adesso
quando quando avrà finito caricare se
proprio in prova preme un tasto se vedi
delle barre di volume sul programma di
ubs vuol dire che anche loro lo sentono
bene ma se parliamo sono fiducioso hai
finito
non è che crociata sta ancora caricando
fiat che palle
intanto vi racconto una bella
barzelletta si racconta le barzellette
ciccia affatto finito ecco quale però
non sento non ho tirato dal microfono ma
come sentiranno po meno sono gain
aspetta schiaccia l'occhio giornata mi
schiaccia
[Musica]
si muoveva capire cosa
di più
[Musica]
beh più o meno ne vado vai è una cosa
molto molto che devo capire come come
mettermi in posizionarmi c6 z sono
ansiolitico no global
l'accordo trovato da un amico rai non mi
ricordo più quindi devo che avesse la
prima volta devo provare mi chiese un
concerto
devo provare
[Musica]
male
no
[Musica]
basta ancora
e poi non mi ricordavo più il pattern
perché era da un mese che non lo facevo
però così e poi li fai tutti ragazzi la
faccia di chi c è qualcosa che non è
difficilissima e carino tutti i tasti a
capitolare che non mi ricordo compiere
un mese che non lo so non devi
ricordarti memorizzati tutti i tassi non
mi ricordavo che non è solo soprattutto
non saprei fare già meno
il finale è figo perché fa tipo e non mi
posso fare l'avvocato
[Musica]
brava anche vita
e poi ci metti un po a ricordarti tutte
da un mese che non lo faccio oggi stai
dietro ma è bello e molto carino si è
ben launch pad
ci sono vari progetti come funziona cioè
tu ai progetti hai dei tipo quelli di
the divenga di sony vegas questo
programma dove tu carichi il progetto e
lui ha incorporato i suoni su ogni tasto
ai 64 tasti per ogni pattern e cenai 8
quindi 60 48
ognuno di questi ha un una melodia
diversa quindi questo è questo quello
del drop e il quarto con la mano
sinistra da me è una merda edifici di
pregio e qualità e ogni ogni suono alla
propria luce e pattern di luci che tutti
incorporato noi paghiamo per conosci
mittente la piana
esatto ciccio quanti giochi
[Musica]
berlino il tuo vicino non ho paura di te
vediamo giuntemi insieme cos'è cose a
caso per quest'area si rimondi a caso è
stato è stato molto carino
beh veste lunch waldner ci sono un sacco
di progetti io adesso mi ricordavo solo
questo però però fa all'inizio ora che
non è difficile ma come scrive tavole si
vede tutto in divisa allora devi usare
tutte le mani perché sono un casino
diventerà con ogni decisione
[Musica]
esatto
i potenti il trucco e memorizzati come
se fossero pezzi di tetris
[Musica]
mi piace perché già aerei
eh sì perché il problema che
[Musica]
park
devi abbiamo offerto alla fine
[Musica]
né vicino dove basta giocar baloccarci
con per fare un'ultima volta si e tu
avevo provavi prendo il nuovo mio
bambino e che difetta
vieni in garage
[Musica]
il bari curcio fatti indietro ed un bel
air debito bellaria volumi kaos one lo
lorenzo puri
non è con doni
ora il dottore è vero adesso sì
veramente papi dj piaciuto dai basta
vergogna vergogna
cioè non tu però in generale ci si
vergogna quando si ci si deve esibire in
qualcosa che si sta imparando esatto
spazio che come ma poi ci spariamo
ginocchiata contro il tav certo no a tre
secondi dalla fine perché io sono stato
tutto il giorno col portale spiego
perché non si sa mai
io dovevo andare con jerome che doveva
andare con gianna fare delle cose no
alla fine gli ho dato pacco da un
momento all'altro sede ma non perché ti
vedevi l'ora lì non l'ho guardato sta
tutto il pomeriggio a settare il bayern
che vorrei fare le misure sulla htc fa
anche il varco il figo non sono andato a
fare quello devo fare perché ho tentato
di mettere i vaghi sul portatile il
prima che il portatile alla scheda
grafica integrata quindi c'è un peschi e
mai prima che con lo posso mettere
allora solo dopo sono arrivati sembrò lo
sfortunato ho provato da cipro di
scollegare tutto ed una norma sai cosa
mi la soluzione c'è la rido cavi su cavi
di qui o di là
è semplicemente un cavo da 5 metri si è
ma mi è venuto in mente solo dopo otto
ore
allora l'unica sbatta qual è allora ti
dovresti recuperare anche un mouse
wireless è così perché sennò ogni modo
di ok ci sono c'è qualcosa che non va e
devi ritornare qui la dottoressa settare
tornare di labro devo mettere cose come
faccia vedere i monitori la devo mettere
un mix di no puoi vederlo tramite il
il live tramite il pied quando sei nella
schermata di gioco lo dovresti poter
vedere altrimenti la prima volta che lo
fai lo fai con qualcuno che sta di
queste tre set
che bello piero da registrare però mi sa
dire sacrati sei solo un cavo perché ci
sono anche le camere non dovresti
pensare al giu le camere per ogni camera
non ho le camere sono tutte a posto il
cavo hdmi deve entrare nella scheda
video e il cavo usb al computer quindi
due capito non sb e lega valle del
belice loro è il bike è stato attaccato
in cosino chitarra e di la moglie alla
fine poi date anche l'astice capito
davvero cosa penso anch'io volevo
passare dalla webcam perché io ho anche
la logica che ci 920 e la 5 22 volo
passano anche alla camera di vera e
propria solo cosa così il cane il cam
link non è infatti un attimo la qualità
me l'hanno consigliato gli altra l'altro
oggi dopo trovare 16 massima non posso
farlo si posso parma cento che puoi
farlo allora spetta ti faccio vedere un
pezzo di live dell'ingv fatto vedere il
video
insomma una draga non me la posso far
vedere scherzavo perché deve uscire un
video sul mio canale tra domani che vedo
deve uscire giorno giovedì giovedì esce
un video ok ok ho capito di avere capito
no il live da una idea del proprio lo
sapeva
e beh in tutto questo che centraggio
condanno la gioconda centrale ci sta
perché non so se sapete ma quando
abbiamo giocato tempo fa io e lorenzo
insieme al pacchetto era contro i
francesi li abbiamo schiacciati siccome
francese non la gioconda in realtà è
nostra io che ho proposto di classe di
italiano non è il classico nero medio
the picture of the world is our quindi è
no se ne ha urlato angela si va bene
basta che evans back the monna lisa è
normale che vinca su questo noi volevamo
appunto rubare laboratory sergio voti
dei ladri team simulator però ce vò lui
sia dotato rubato il quadro che si
facevano o proprio via allora infatti la
nuova carino per quadro va bene
pennellate lorella soprattutto noi che
ci intendiamo di arte non fa un cazzo si
vabbè ma non credo di aver mai avuto tra
l'altro un finale così vi fico sei
veramente mi sono divertito tantissimo
cioè col botto di no basta cioè mi
piaceva a chiuderla così in
intellettuale ci stavano in 3d ha
cercato decisivo per una volta che
possono alterare dieci minuti parliamo
che tu sei sa criticatissimo già parlava
delle vostre esperienze riguardanti
youtube cosa che cosa ci è successo di
brutto di brutto sono finito sulle gambe
di uno youtuber una volta una volta una
sono due cioè a una è la più amata e
prima quando mi sono messo poi mi sono
stato per una cosa bella quindi è una
cosa bella e brutta
su di me una cosa brutta mai quante
donne vorrebbero fuso le mie gambe da un
applauso la madre demandare fire costo
uno di recco di martin garics quando
mining che in questa casa cioè il geki
vigevano dato questa casa in cui sony
già chi per tale camminavo noi lo ha
abbandonato
e noi dobbiamo per terra dice ok qui per
farmi la doccia l'acqua ora guarda caso
la quindi fuori la gara c'è una pompa 12
aspetto ok pd a pompa una pompa per
farla per azionarla tour c'è un elastico
della bomba piegata tutto vero
l'elastico alza la pompa causa sarà un
enigma di monchio questa pompa però avrà
anche dei mughetti riusciva anche a noi
e farci la doccia
se c'è gente cammina davanti la casa
perché là davanti al mare quindi è stata
la gente passava quindi costretto a
farti la nomina degli altri
certo non con canti fuori chiunque io mi
vergogno viene nettamente il costume
quindi sotto la loro sfida al quadro se
non avesse avuto la macchina la casa di
stava e non sto scherzando dal dal
concerto a casa almeno 20 km he la
madonna mi arrivava in un potere
no noi ha detto quanta musica non si fa
niente purtroppo equa ed isabel cibo e
pagato il viaggio è pagato neanche
guerra roma ci sono biglietti ma vi ci
hanno obbligato quindi non è qui che
doveva pro potendo guardare l'invito
perché voglio invitare lewis ma roma non
amiamo risponde venivi tote artisti
boccalone ti sei fatto proprio da
manovra che va da thorne ha risposto li
abbiamo tutto ok io ti offro il
biglietto mentre al concerto vivono a
casa è e non stato anche il backstage
con del back stage con scene action pole
ancora vivo sia pure fatto un tetto
della madonna bellissimo arrivo la ok è
vero
alla fine del corso sono dei ring dove
devo andare anno dell perdonarlo non sa
dove andare via perché qua non si può
non si può in che senso scusi di qua e
non so fare che qual è il problema prima
non può restare qua ok sarebbe aspettato
un'ora e mezzo il sole il caldo totale
del brodetto brezzi abbiamo ceneri e ci
siamo andati dopo marco minuti e mandare
a foto con lui con mark in gare così ma
no dai
veramente brutto una idea
idea avresti potuto ucciderlo davvero no
vabbè ma ce l'hai detto certo che hanno
guardato aperto tu hai invitato però
come ci avete trattato come come sono
organizzate le cose 0
non per niente la scorci tanto [ __ ] è
nei geni erano gratis tematiche legate
però deve analizzare quelli che qui
tranquillanti misti niente non
inviteremo i concerti
se sei tu e chiara spiace un sacco
comunque davvero liberi da tirare fuori
quella canzone gelate chiediamo bye bye
bye pro tanto è bastato lo sa invadono
certa ed il problema è che la devi
mettere nelle cuffie devi tenere solo
super mai detto quale che apprezzeremo
al massimo ma se la mette nelle cuffie
la sentono punti ok tranne
noi due ragazzi a letto qua così tutto
non mi sento tanto io so voi ma gli
spiriti ispiration all music e
strumentali ok fatto gli studenti
ragazzi e rondò sito di networking
massimo se gli metti di andare qui ne
apprezziamo ragazzi la notte vi lasciamo
la chiusura anzi che dio ce li copiano
e una notte grazie per essere stati con
noi una nota a tutti ragazzi è stato un
piacere
buonanotte a chi ha preso le botte ma io
no logo a casa di lorenzo con gianandrea
io lo penso
[Musica]
noi e questa life
beh l'abbiamo dedicata
io vi guardo mi metto a dieta e maggioni
insalata
io vi voglio bene ma mai vaio guardo il
teg e te lo dico io sono ciccio berretti
si no
lorenzo mi guarda e ride qua intanto
canto ha d
io ho
chi è ok va bene
dammi una sigaretta il fumo qua mi sento
stretto una camera da letto così la
vorrei per la mia vita domani ogni t te
lo dico io canto ogni giorno questo sono
io
ciccio e sono un pasticcio
mi metto a piangere per favore di meno a
me
chi è
lorenzo ti voglio bene per me sei un
fratello ti prego previ il pisello
guardami la verdura non altro tool
mi guardi negli occhi io ti dico ti
dedico i botti quella capodanno ogni
giorno una volta l'anno
te lo dico io questo l'ho io ciao ciao
[Musica]
andrea e lorenzo riguardano il ci pensa
ciao
[Musica]
ascolta lorenzo per questo e per te
però
buonanotte a tutti e chi ci ha fatto
compagnia pure a te
ieri
per favore guarda questo nato se mi giro
guarda quando
yahoo
wow
veramente grande con gli occhiali sembro
un grande
ti voglio bene
[Musica]
via
[Applauso]
ciao
yahoo
[Musica]
[Applauso]